I would say it's easily in a million
lines absolutely the algorithm is meant
to indicate all of the different methods
we use who decide which search results
we're going to show you and in what
order or which recommendations we're
going to choose for you I think people
when they refer to the algorithm they
mean all the all the code that we've
written to do those things I don't think
of it as one thing I think of it as lots
of little pieces that are trying to
accomplish the overall goal of
connecting you with what you're looking
for or what we think you might want want
to watch it's not like a piece of code
hidden in a safe or something there's no
piece of code hidden in a safe there's a
lot of code and it's scattered all over
the place in our code base if you look
closely at it it'll resemble much more
counting than any sort of dark
sophisticated thing there is whether
it's the algorithm or whatever it is
there is a degree of secrecy isn't there
for good or bad reasons I mean you you
can't be completely open about all of
this can you or you're not open about
all of it it seems you is that a fair
comment I mean I think we're quite open
about what we're trying to achieve and I
think we're open about the instances
where we know it's not working and we
think it can be better I tend to be a
little bit more reticent to discuss
exactly how we're doing it and there's a
few reasons first of all we don't want
people to try to game what we're doing
and sadly we do see that on YouTube and
so everything we do we have to think
about the opportunities for gaming it I
mean we're using certain kinds of
information to help people find the
videos they're looking for that depends
on on that being that information coming
from sincere viewers who were actually
looking for things now if instead it
came from a robot it wasn't really
looking for anything it was just trying
to make sure that a particular video
showed up at the top of some search
results or you know had a tremendous
number of views then then we can't use
that anymore and so it's not just that
there's a few more in
is of poor search results or inflated
view counts but but it's worse than that
because actually that's that means that
that we can't use the thing that we were
using anymore and so now we have to you
know we have to take that away as a
possibility for helping associate the
viewers with the videos they want to
watch and then move on to the next thing
and then of course that thing may also
be abused and so you know we have to try
to protect these these signals as we
call them so that so that we don't lose
them and you know and then we're left
with with very little to actually go on
I don't want to lock us into a
particular way of doing things you know
say for instance that five years ago
ranking the search results by the view
count may have been a great thing to do
and that was because at that time view
count was one of the best signals that
you could find for what are the quality
of the video well since then we've found
other things that are that are even
better and we don't want people to
become upset when they say hey wait a
minute these videos aren't ranked in the
order of the view count that's wrong
what's not wrong because we like I said
we would have done an experiment to find
that there was actually a better way to
do it yes we take a view count into
account but there's some other thing
that we might want to do for instance a
very good example is if it were just
ranked by view count you've never seen
any new videos so you type plane crash
after a plane crashes and you'd see the
oldest plane crash footage we have if we
want to have some video of the new
incident we can't rank everything by
view count we don't want to commit
ourselves in a way to people thinking
that this is the way it has to be and
that we can't make any changes because
we have to we have to make changes
you mentioned view I mean view account
is very transparent signal because of
the design of YouTube can you mention
some of the other signals you're using
sure what one of those that we started
using a couple of years ago now I guess
was watch time so what we noticed was
that was that when people looked for
videos it was often the case that they
would
see one that looked like the video they
wanted to watch but then once they got
on that watch page it wasn't actually
the video they were wanting to watch
maybe it had a thumbnail that was you
know very misleading or a title that was
particularly misleading now fortunately
in most of those cases eventually they
got to the one they were looking for and
often that was because that would be
somewhere on the related videos but in
looking in that situation we thought
well gee that's kind of crummy because
why should I have to click two or three
times in order to finally get to a video
that I was looking for we tried to
figure out how to fix that not well
people tend to know fairly quickly
whether or not the video they've landed
on is the one they're looking for
the best example I remember of this was
we saw one where there were several
videos that had titles about a
particular boxing match and one of them
especially had a thumbnail of a guy like
he was just about to be hit and his you
know his fist was right up in the other
guy's face and everybody was going to
click on that one what turned out that
the video behind that was a person
talking about the fight and it had no
footage of the fight and eventually the
viewers would finally get to the one
that had some footage of the fight when
we looked into that situation we
realized that one way to detect the
difference between these was one of
these videos wasn't getting watched very
much and the other one was what for very
long or watch for very long exactly one
of them wasn't getting watched very long
and the other one was and so instead of
just ranking the videos by how often
they were clicked in response to a query
we rank them for how much they they were
watched in response to a query and so
that helped that situation quite a bit
how often are you twiddling the dials
and refining this and tweaking this is
this like a daily thing with little
things that can change or is it like a
once a year big implementation we've
we've always got at least I don't know
ten different changes that we're working
on and they may take somewhere between a
few weeks to serve
months to finally launch and there's
usually some some analysis and intuition
and then there's some implementation
some changes that you're gonna make to
the code and then there's lots of
experimentation and evaluation in order
to confirm that this change actually
benefits the viewers and so how many
times do we do it a year maybe 50 times
a year or a hundred times a year other
things that believers that can be pulled
like okay today we're gonna put 21
percent emphasis on watch time and no no
it needs to be 19 percent is it is it
like that it's not really like that
because all of those settings or levers
or or all the code that we've written to
make those kinds of decisions has been
has been tuned based on evaluation and
analysis of some kinds of experiments or
other ways we have of rating changes and
so it wouldn't make sense for us to walk
in and say well I'm you know I'm feeling
like we ought to put a higher weight on
something even if I were to feel that we
ought to put a higher weight and one
watch time for instance what that would
amount to is some of the engineers doing
several weeks worth of experiments to
see whether or not putting a higher
weight on watch time resulted in more
people getting to the videos they watch
faster
we can see the data that we've got now
the data that we get back is completely
random it depends where when the server
received that message we put it in same
computer's memory so this time when
we've run it it's actually giving us
some useful information because we have
demonstrated some evidence you know in
the broader subs or another way that we
might find to recommend things